our love observation of all
the ministry was not outdone they
always diverge beyou kentish
pipes at what is love is you nadine is
enough week michel barnier so
there were fake education directory
they have the double ready for the next
five you are progressing minatchy index das
note
milliman debt of thomson son and i
had the opportunity to say that we had
felt since
theresa may's florence speech a new dynamic
which was necessary and everything must be
done to preserve this dynamic
l  meeting in the next few months with the
council
this week will be like a springboard
to the next meeting
as soon as objectively I could not
see the progress that we were
expecting on the first phase of the
negotiations, the
ministers unanimously approved  this observation of a
state of insufficient progress on the
major subjects of the settlement of the
separation that the British have
decided the account is not there at the moment
Where I'm talking to you the account isn't there
that's what the ministers have seen
with me I'm going to continue to work
patiently to find the path to the
progress that needs to be made by
December by maintaining the
dynamic that I mentioned earlier